avant le match débluer l'ancien
sélectionneur français Philippe
Saint-André est revenu au micro de RMC
sur un épisode traumatisant de
l'histoire du rugby français en 95 en
fait la France affroné les Africains du
Sud les Sud-Africains pour les puristes
au finale du Mondial le match avait été
remporté par les Sud-Africains mais en
fait il y avait eu des il y avait eu il
y avait eu des bails parce qu'en fait he
Jacques et Gill il paraî qu'en fait ils
avaient triché lesafricains bah oui on a
dit beaucoup qu'ils avaient triché
d'abord on a parlé de dopage puis
tricherai avec l'arbitre voilà quoi ils
ont triché pas du tout ils auraient ils
avaient ils auraient ils auraient
prendre empoisonné les néozélandais hein
voilà donc ils savaient pas ça et c'est
pas de la triche ça bah si si ils
auraient voilà une monte de 30000 €
aurait été offerte à l'arbitre ouais
parce qu'il avait pas l'heure par qu'il
avait pas l'heure et un arbitre qui a
pas l'heure c'est un arbitre qui peut
être en retard bah c'est ça enfin ceux
qui ont la méthode Anouna c'est ça quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il y a bah enfin la M alors
to sors
grave chef c'est grave ce qui vient de
se quand on est con quand on est con on
est con allez et merci alors et de il y
a eu quatre essai refusés au français
ouis quatre essaiis refusés au français
un essai aurait pu être marqué si les
sudafricain n'avait pas écroulé CIN fois
la Mée ce qui est interdit aujourd'hui
avec l'avar ça ne serait pas arrivé donc
il y a eu des triches incroyables parce
que c'était en africain du Sud sudri che
les Africains sud-afrique ouis
sudafrique et là sudafrique et là tout
le monde a poussé un coup même Thomas
Pesquier Thomas pesqu normalement il
pousse jamais de coup gueule il est
toujours en apesanteur
c'est la
PH un coup de guule comme ça il a les
mêm chaussures il a les mê
ch c'est pas possible le rugby est un
sport qui d'habitude se joue à 15 contre
15 mais en plus de se faire voler il
faut se taper les mecs frustrés qui
connaissent pas les règles ça va bien là
personne parlerit en Belgique quand la
France a gagné tout le monde disait que
c'était un beau match avec deux bonnes
équipes et pourtant rien à voir niveau
arbitrage sans s déconner oh et ouais et
ouais quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a à to il
retourne dans sa fusée quoi c'est bon
comme ça pesqu je te jure non mais mais
toi sans rigoler mais tu vois pas que
tout le monde est énervé mais toi sans
rigoler toi tu acceptes toi tu acceptes
l'inacceptable c'est ce que tu fais
depuis des années avec ton couple et tu
veux le faire aussi dans le rugby
excusez-moi je suis énervé la France a
perdu je je suis fou de cette équipe de
France que j'adore les gars qui jouent
j'ai eu mon pote Christian labite ce
matin on été dépité et toi tu acceptes
inacceptable toi toi tu te fais voler he
bah c'est pareil c'est comme quand il y
a un squatter chez toi tu es content
soyons digne dans la défaite c'est tout
ce que je dis arrête un ne soyons pas
digne dans la défaite on s'est fait
voler voler voler
voler c'est français ça ça m'étonne de
vous vous êtes un compétiteur du tout on
s fait voler ça m'étonne pas de toi en
tout cas Mor il pas qu'est-ce qu'il a
pas le moral on s'est fait voler lui dit
rien même même pour se défendre il est
pas c'est la pochette là c'est la
pochette mais c'est bien français ça
arrête un peu français c'est toi
on a perdu on a perdu et non alors c'est
l'arbitre même le sélectionneur il dit
pas comme du tout bah oua moi je le dis
et même Antoine Dupont l'a dit ouais
mais pas les studau du
P St moi je suis pas d'accord comment on
l'a dit et toi tu to tu ta gueule non
c'est pesk ouvre sa gueule moi je dis
rien tu parles pas comme ça de PES
retoures dans la
lune je te dis parle pas comme ça de
pesk j'ad conna le rugby PES con r PES
j'adore pesk Mo conna rugbyou PES il
connait rien à Ren PES il connait très
bien il connaus con un compétiteur fais
gaffe qu'il a pas une fusé qui fin dans
ton
cul je te le dis je commence à en avoir
assez de toi non non mais et tu parles
pas comme ça de Tom PES je l'adore
j'adore Thomas pesk non mais je te dis
tu pas obligé de retirer tu dis ce que
tu veux maisom il est nul il nous fait
chier il nous fait chier retourne sur la
Lune il régal est frustré de la lune
calmei frustré de la Lune par pas
il est frustré parce il marchera pas sur
la Lune là voilà il est frustré je veux
dire s'il y en a bien un qui a plus vu
la lune que toi c'est
lui ça
pesqu pas Pesquer hein ni Pesquer ni
Pasquier les brioches brioch brioch ok
je donne rien ok ni les pit je te le dis
les pit on touche pas au
pitch ok ni pesqu ni pasqu ni les pach
ok il fasse des photos là en calme-toi
làha bah lui au moins il est sur orbite
c'est pas ce qui est pas ton
cas bon g AR arrête c'est une boucherie
arrête c'est une
boucherie un problème
toi Arte qu'est tu vuxen dire retourne
dans ton camion c'est ça tu es en
difficulté tu m'enfonces tu parles d'un
pote toi je voulais pas difficulté on
s'est fait voler mon Gilou on s'est fait
voler arrêtez arrêtez la pénalité c'est
quand même très bizarre mais cardos il
connais quoi rugby foout ils t'ont
[Applaudissements]
viréon les
gars touche pas cardose he non plus
touche pas card cardos je peux toucher à
personne alors touche à ton cul ok non
mais je te dis touche pas card mais g
arrête un peu non mais la pénalité comme
elle Estée qu'est-ce qu'il y a biz Racon
bien sûr la pénalité cont cour vite il
cour très vite le petit et toi aussi tu
vas courir très vite pour aller
retrouver Fatou là petit calme-i
normement arbitrage à la maison ça
arbitrage à la maison ça passe pas ça je
te le dis donc toi parce que si toi à la
maison tu te fais arbitrer comme de la
merde et ben nous non je te le dis voilà
nous je te le dis parce que là je te dis
que tu es pas prêt de passer entre les
poteaux toi ouais alors pour mettre tout
le monde d'accord alors elle c'est la
juge avait raison en fait
[Applaudissements]
alors elle elle arrive c'est le tribunal
Géraldine maillet c'est bon voilà bah le
maillet de toute façon bam voilà elle
est là bam alors elle pour trancher
accusz levezbous Gil Verdez merci non
justement je voulais tendre une main à
Gill alors bah si tu pour lui tendre une
main pour lui mettre une tarte c'est pas
la peine non dit-moi non justement il y
a qu'une personne vraiment qui s'y
connaît ici en rugby vraiment bah oui on
est d'accord ouais mcttar c'est le
spécialiste rugby ici dans cette pice il
a deux spécialités mocttar c'est quoi la
deuxè le rugby et les sandwichuton
malheureusement malheureusement il y a
pas de championnat du monde de
chandwiuton il aurait pu il aurait pu le
dire donc vous êtes le producteur et
c'est vous qui décidez mais est-ce qu'on
ne pourrait pas lui tendre un micro et
que vraiment en toute transparence en
toute vérité il nous disent vraiment
merci c'est pas la peine de c'est bon
alors
bonsoirc alors on est venu dans le
public il est venu avec qui celui-ci
tout seul e
avec cègues alors je suis pas les
Anglais moi je te le dis alors quoi tu
es d'accord avec moi ouais on s'est fait
voler mon de fou non mais il a raison
mais les mecs on s'est fait voler sur
quelle action par rapport déjà sur
toutes les action toutes les
pratiquement toutes les bien sûr lui il
connait le rugby toi qu'est-ce que tu
connais
toi transformation
transform de Ramos bien s Colby part
avant avant qu'il s' lance
voilà M court vite mm il est 5 m tu as
vu les images ouais non mais il a pas vu
les images il j'ai regardé le match
mieux que toi tu étais au bord du stade
alors s j'étais là ouas pas V comme tu
étais où to moi j'étais devant ma télé
j'ai revu 10 foisour tu sais quoi bah
regarde l'émission depis ta télé aussi
tu vois merci donc on s'est fait voler
de fou merci
Mo il est pas bien il est pas bien
là je suis dégoûté ou et dis-moi comme
moi si on avait gagné ce match on était
champion du monde bah oui bien sûr c'est
fini après c'était des kiches Loren je
te le dis voilà il y avac que des kiches
Loren les Anglais c'est des pipes et
après les la Nouvelle-Zélande on les a
déjà battu c'est des pipes aussi voilà
et nous qu'est-ce qu'on va se retrouver
à la maison alors que les les Africains
du Sud ben ils sont en train de
kifferriain bah les Sud-Africains voilà
les Spring Box hein voilà comment on
appelle les
oui on redescend et les Australiens
comment on les appellent les wabis ouais
my d'accord j'aime bien ah
c'est plus le même plus le même délire
euh